millions of Americans turning out to
vote the new Congress will be divided
with Democrats leading the house and
Republicans in charge of vicinity I will
tell you will keep me going until the
end of the year the Democrats were like
it's gonna be the blue wave and then it
was like like it was like the wave at a
stadium where it's kind of like half
excited I don't know how to feel
am I gonna be wearing a handmade tail
bonnet in two years that's what I want
to know I think there and I gonna be a
man's property at any point in the next
five years have we gotten anywhere
closer or further from that I don't know
a lot of uh politics where that seems
where it's going I could never run for
office though I have too much baggage my
press conference would also be my
resignation speech my name is Dan st.
Germain I'm running for Senator mr. st.
Germain in 2015 did you hit on a woman
of the 9/11 museum I'm suspending my
candidacy yes then a great run
I saw a gang beating up an old lady
today and I walked over like what the
hell were you doing they were like she
didn't vote I was like okay that makes
sense I walked up to a guy who's an old
man and he had a Vietnam War hat on pío
w and I was like oh you're a Pio W so I
guess we're the same you know just a
couple of heroes
I know black people attire though we
really tired so we've just
voting for black people right now and I
know white people trying to make us feel
good like oh you only voted for Obama
because he's black
yeah we vote for everything Jamal
tray ray-ray little rail all the niggas
we vote for them yeah
if there was a candidate named Nicky
Mickelson I would vote for him you
understand right
white people both white people too
that's why the y'all still in power
ain't enough niggas vote so we got to
get out of oh where the camera
[Applause]
you